Rebecca is with us in Effingham Illinois
hi Rebecca
Merry Christmas there coz the same I
wish I was calling like with an exciting
question but I'm not basically
my husband and I were doing the baby
steps to her own baby step - and you're
talking about bonuses and stuff and they
thought we would be able to be done
maybe at the beginning of the year and
then he kind of Tom really told me I was
I'm going to tell you and he had
actually still been using a credit card
all year that he didn't tell me about so
so you guys were in agreement you
thought to work your way out of debt
meanwhile he's in the background lying
and using a credit card is that what
you're telling me yes for how I know
about a year maybe nine months so this
wasn't really passive in that we just
weren't talking about it and I didn't
know about his dad no we're working a
get out of debt plan and he's just
straight up lying in the background and
I wasn't I was asking every about every
month because I wasn't we weren't
meeting so obviously weren't like as
good as well intense as we should so you
weren't working a plan we I thought we
were working the plans I thought we were
at least surviving and maybe not right
we were not working it obviously how
it's okay I'm a little bit confused you
know if you're working at plan if you're
working a plan you're hedging like crazy
here and I don't know whether you're
trying to save his hide or whether
you're just trying to I don't know
what's going on
so let's if you had an a solid agreement
we are getting out of debt
we're not borrowing money anymore that's
different than I thought we were
surviving right which is it I thought we
were sitting out of that we were really
low income and so I knew it wasn't going
to be as fast you're so involved there's
no nobody needed to hide anything from
you
yeah you know it doesn't he didn't hide
anything you just didn't show up to ask
he was just doing his thing you were
doing your thing you guys did not have
agreement you were not working a plan
that's what you're telling me with all
this edging or you're trying to save his
hide I can't tell which because I'm
gonna really kill him otherwise shock
processing mode about also how much
credit card debt is there it's about
nine thousand which for the general
world is not that much fun oh and what
is your household income about thirty
five okay thirty-five yeah oh okay right
and how much other debt if you got even
if doubles like a tick what was the
question how much other than have you
got that's it okay well what I would say
is this has exposed this knowledge of
this debt has exposed two major things
that if I'm your husband and I'm you I'm
going to have alarm bells going off like
the house is burning down these two
things must be addressed okay number one
you are not on a plant and you're not
working together and you're not
communicating and you're not doing a
budget every month and you are just
trying to survive and that's not going
to work you're a rat in a wheel it's
killing both of you he was doing the
best he could do but he didn't want to
worry you and so he's you know paying
off bills with these credit cards he
didn't go to Europe on them with his
girlfriend okay so you know he's just a
good guy doing a stupid but thing the
wrong way and it's time to stop it so
the two of you together there's the
house is on fire you have to you have to
grab each other's hands and go we can't
do this anymore we can't do this more
it's gonna kill us it's gonna kill our
marriage that's gonna kill everything
because I'm I'm starting to be really
really pissed about this debt and you
got a lot of shame about it and we got
to get on the same page and we got to
write this down and we gotta have a
budget and we got to get an attack mode
does that sound right yeah okay the the
second thing that this exposes it is
that your all's income is struggling and
we need a game plan to get the income up
short
and long-term to be able to attack this
debt and maybe even to balance your
budget Frank
and so what is his you know how old is
he
30 okay so when he's 45 what is he going
to be doing making a hundred well he's
in ministry oh we don't know okay is he
a pastor is it you that he's a youth
pastor okay and sadly translation that
means in most cases you starve to death
right most youth pastors don't make much
yeah choir director youth pastor most of
them struggle it's very low paid
positions sadly I wish it wasn't it
should it should be a higher priority in
a higher paid position but we can talk
of philosophy while you starve to death
so I think he's got it aside how he can
flesh out God's calling in his life
while providing a larger income to his
family right I'm not saying quit your
job today but there's not a lot of 45 or
55 year old youth pastors so we got it
where are we going with this what's
God's what's God telling us to do what's
our calling I'm not doubting that he's
called to the ministry and glad he's
called to the ministry but we need to
think about how we're gonna eat here and
how we're going to be able to make the
bills and how we're gonna escalate in
our career and pastors need to grow in
their careers like anyone else
and they need to grow there in the
effectiveness of their ministry the
wisdom of their ministry the depth of
their ministry and and there's nothing
illegal in scripture about making more
money as a result of that agent and I'm
not suggesting he become a prosperity
guy that's not what I'm talking about
but obviously a pastor who leads a 3,000
member congregation typically makes more
than the youth pastor that has 30 kids
in a small Church and you know that
that's the truth now those 30 kids
important and God's eyes yes they are
there's an economic transaction that
occurs even in minute
three and it's not it doesn't make money
Yvonne it would make you evil to think
about that for the good of your family
hey guys thanks for watching if you
enjoyed this video click the subscribe
button to get the latest content and
check out these other great clips from
the show